so with the second half of Infinity
Gauntlet issue number six we get a
conclusion to this story we get an end
to the Infinity Gauntlet event and
picking up where we left off with
Infinity Gauntlet issue number six part
one what we saw was that Adam warlock
had attained the Infinity Gauntlet for
himself and that he had promised to be a
fair and just God and so what we see
Adam warlock saying here is that he
promises to use this power wisely that
he promises not to abuse this power in
the same fashion that nebula or Thanos
had and what's really interesting here
is that for the most part Adam warlock
seems very sincere here he seems as
though it really is his intention to be
a good guy and the question that the
incredible hulk has is what are they
gonna do about that us and nebula what's
going to happen with them now
interaction a story of course being a
being that was created for the
destruction of Thanos takes it upon
himself to say the Thanos is his that
he's going to try to kill thanos here
but of course Thanos is easily able to
overpower both the Incredible Hulk and
Drax the destroyer from here we switched
to Thanos saying that he's activated
some kind of a thermonuclear device on
his belt line and that it's set to
activate in about 15 seconds and Silver
Surfer asks why why would fan o's kill
himself and that o says that for him
death is preferential to imprisonment
now he doesn't necessarily explicitly
say this but i would even go as far as
to speculate that for Thanos if he were
to die he would find absolute happiness
within the realm of mistress death but
again every instance that we've seen
with Thanos where he has gone
after mistress death has always been an
attempt to be by her side to be her
equal more so than a person who simply
just exists inside her realm and so what
we see is that Eric Masterson takes the
hammer of Thor
and hits Thanos with it and when he does
stano's is knocked away from the newly
restored shrine of mistress death and
out into the depths of space where he
explodes presumably killing him and this
is what everybody takes thought
everybody takes on this mantle that
Thanos has been killed that Thanos is
now dead he's no longer part of this
conflict anymore and so we see that eros
Suppan says that as a member or
represent a a representative of the
state of Titan that he's taking custody
of nebula for himself and eros has
grounds to do this because again as far
as everybody here knows nebula is a real
relative of Thanos and so by extension
she's a relative of Eros and so eros is
for the most part just settling family
issues here and so that Adam warlock
agrees with this Adam warlock says
that's fine and he teleports eros Drax
the destroyer nebula away but then also
teleports the Incredible Hulk away
presumably back to the planet Earth and
so the only people that we have left are
the Silver Surfer Erik Masterson and dr.
strange and the question is asked here
by by the silver surfer is why why are
they still here when everybody else has
been sent away and Adam warlock says
that they have gazed into his into the
depths of his heart they know him the
way nobody else does and for the most
part Adam warlock is saying here that
they are the only individuals who know
him well enough that when he says that
he will be a god who can be trusted that
he means it and so he sends them forward
to tell other people this is true and
again this is very much tapping into the
element of Adam warlock representing a
Jesus Christ like figure in Marvel
Comics because again if you go back and
watch our discussion on Adam warlock if
you go back in and listen to what it was
that we were saying that Adam warlock
was introduced to us as a christ-like
figure he had simply just emerged one
day he was created he was I guess
crucified by man beast on the counter
earth during that storyline and of
course he had resurrected himself on
several occasions and so this is tapping
back into that in the same way that
Jesus had for informed his disciples
that he was truly the Son of God and to
go forth and to spread his word that
Adam warlock is doing much the same
thing and for the most part what we see
is that these superheroes are kind of
questioning this they're saying is this
really true can they really go forward
and say that Adam warlock is a fair and
true God because as Doctor Strange says
absolute power corrupts absolutely
and Adam warlock asks them if the idea
of replacing their chaos the chaos that
is their lives with order if it would be
something unpalatable and again what we
see is that they're reacting in such a
way to where for them this is scary that
not only would their lives be
irrevocably changed if Adam warlock
chose to do so but that Adam warlock
looks at them as chaotic beings and that
his role is to replace their chaos with
order to in effect make the universe the
way he sees fit and so for them they
look at this as though he's taking the
first few steps towards becoming
corrupted by the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet
but Adam warlock is able to quell the
concerns to a degree he says that the
distance between who he was now or who
he was then and who he is now is
something insurmountable that not even
he realizes the differences and that he
thought that he could speak with them
and tell them that he would be fair he
thought that he could demonstrate that
he would be a fair God but that it
doesn't seem as though they are willing
to to buy into this cause and so what we
see is that Adam warlock teleports them
away at this point we switch to Adam
warlock 60 days into the future with
Gamora and pip and what Adam warlock
tells pip is that they're going to meet
someone they're going to go on a journey
and he says for the most part that this
is something that's happened time and
time again and so what it seems is that
Adam warlock has manipulated the time
gem to travel 60 years into the future
on several occasions to see if it's
possible for things to turn out
differently but what he tells us is that
it always turns out the same way and so
what we see is they're walking along is
that it appears that the Thanos is
standing in the cornfields the Thanos is
simply just waiting their arrival but
when they get to it they realize it is
simply just a scarecrow wearing his suit
and Adam warlock comments on this and
says that it's an empty shell of what
was that it appears as though Thanos has
cast aside his old mantle of attempting
to usurp absolute power and seems to
maybe just be living a quiet life and
indeed that's what we learn we learned
that when they approach a house
relatively close to the corn fields that
Thanos emerges wearing some kind of garb
some kind of maybe monk-like garb or
in alpha this simply just allows him
relative comfort and he tells Adam
warlock that he should have known that
it would be him that he would come for
him eventually and Adam more like more
or less just greets Thanos as a friend
here at their very least if not a friend
as a person who's certainly not an enemy
and so what Adam warlock says is that
there are no secrets from him having
absolute knowledge and absolute power
within the universe grants him the
knowledge of knowing what all is going
on in the universe at that very moment
and so Thanos comments and says that the
memory of having absolute power is very
dim for him and that he asked Adam
warlock why he had waited so long to
gain vengeance and again Adam warlock
comments and says why is it that he
always asks the same question indicating
that this is repeated itself on several
occasions that Adam warlock has traveled
into the future several times and that
this circumstance always plays out the
same way and Thanos seems to recognize
this Thanos says that he supposes that
he always asks the same question and
that is a bit confusing which of course
tells us that Thanos well he doesn't
necessarily recall every facet of the
Infinity Gauntlet event at the very
least remembers what it was like to hold
that absolute power and what Adam
warlock tells Thanos is that he's
looking for some advice more more likely
advice on how to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet effectively and Thanos simply
says to either endure it or to surrender
to its power and Adam warlock says this
really isn't the kind of comfort he was
looking for now what it was that he was
looking for with Thanos is something
that we actually don't learn we don't
learn what it was that he was trying to
gain from Thanos who or what it was he
was trying to get Thanos to say all we
know is that he went to Thanos for
advice on what to do and Thanos gave him
a couple words that didn't really seem
to comfort him that well and so for the
most part Adam warlock Gamora and pip
take their leave they choose to go ahead
and leave vanos to his thoughts and what
we see is it for the most part Thanos is
simply just living a quiet life here
that after everything that's gone on
after everything that has taken place if
Thanos is taking this time to I guess to
collect himself to decide what his next
move is going to be whether or not he's
still going to continue his path for
trying to gain absolute power again or
if he is simply just going to try to
live a quiet
and again touching back on Thanos his
character within the the Marvel Universe
we learn of course later on that Thanos
goes after the heart of the universe
which of course grants him absolute
power once more but for the most part
we're left with Thanos here on his
personal thoughts as he says that for
the most part he thinks that he came out
on top with this particular event that
Adam warlock is is undergoing a process
that he's undergoing a change and that
he holds a heavy burden and the fact
that he has absolute power and so he has
to constantly be on guard he has to
constantly be vigilant because even the
slightest subconscious thought could
lead to the ruin of all and so again
Pharaoh says that he doesn't envy Adam
warlock and that at the end of the day
that after everything is all said and
done that Thanos came out on top here
now his statement in terms of coming out
on top is twofold the first half is that
he's managed to eliminate the burden of
absolute power this is no longer
something he has to deal with and so his
mind is at ease but the other half the
second part of this is that Adam warlock
is going to undergo something called the
trial of warlock whereby he will be
called before the Living Tribunal at the
behest of the cosmic entity eternity
along with the other cosmic entities to
determine whether or not he is capable
of being able to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end and I really hope you guys
enjoy the Infinity Gauntlet story it is
in fact I would consider to be one of
the absolute best stories to ever been
created in the the Marvel Comics events
with that being said I will catch you
guys later peace